hey leute was garten jetzt willkommen
bei myvideo und zwar mit komm du musst
mal wieder irgendetwas neues machen also
was auf dem schirm nicht so gibt und da
ist mir so ein format in den kopf
bekommen also ich find zurzeit snap chat
mega kracher habe ich ja letztens auch
schon mal gesagt also wenn ihr mir da
noch nicht voll vier eingecheckt es auf
jeden fall mal ab und ja auf jeden fall
gehe ich ab und zu auf snapshot so
bilder gesendet da denke ich mir
und genau deswegen bin ich jetzt auf
dieses format gekommen nennt sie einfach
snapshot fans ich haben irgendwelche
snap chat fels rat gesucht also bilder
die einfach keinen sinn ergeben oder
lustig sind meistens jetzt auf dem
internet irgendwas und ja das gibt es
halt einfach mal wenn es euch gefällt
dann lass dir ich denke ich an dieser
stelle genau jetzt die daumen nach oben
da wenn ihr bock auch noch eine zweite
dritte vierte und so weiter voll gehabt
dann daumen nach oben
dann wollen wir gar nicht lange lagern
ich will sagen wir fangen direkt an und
lässt mich das okay ist als erste bild
das ist irgendwann typ der liegt so
offen bett und schläft und dann ist er
wirklich offene klasse idee gekommen ich
mein so man muss jetzt also wenn man
keine freundin hat kann man ja so tun
als hätte man eine und er tut dann halt
auf den jahr meine freunde macht ein
foto von mir während ich schlafe aber
das foto machte eigentlich mit seinen
füßen sieht man ja er hat halt einfach
nicht gecheckt dass da ein spiegel im
hintergrund ist ich weiß auch nicht das
sieht man doch oder aber keine ahnung
auf jeden fall wie cover bitte ein foto
mit seinen füßen machen
ich probiere das mal ich probiere das
mag ja okay leute seht ihr mich gut ich
glaube ich muss meine
trotzdem hatte ok
nein
ja ich habe es geschafft ohne schein ich
habe das geschafft
man sieht mich halt mich guck mal aber
nur ganz leicht aber ich hab's geschafft
kommen wir hier auch schon zum nächsten
feld und zwar dass irgendwann op der
gitarrist einem hund gassi nur sei nur
deshalb ins wasser gesprungen und er
merkt es nicht
oder ist das ein fisch und der typ der
das foto gemacht hat fragt also er soll
ich denn das sagen oder nicht weil das
ist ehrlich als ich das foto gesehen
habe ich fand schon ich fand schon echt
witzig vielleicht ist das bei dem wir
auch ganz normal feld geht ja immer so
sein
schwimmt und er geht kann ja auch sein
ohne witz bei diesem foto muss sich
direkt an diese ganzen mädchen denken
wieso am strand liegen und auch so ein
foto machen ich weiß nicht vielleicht
machen wir auch diese beide von denen
die sehen immer aus wie zwei suppe für
ist jetzt nichts gegen euch aber das
sieht aus wie soja also nicht wie ein
fuß sondern eher wie eine bockwurst wenn
ihr das anders hier können das gerne in
die kommentare schreiben aber ich sehe
das halt so
und der typ dachte sich erika mich
verarscht dass man ist ja meine snap
chat von ora und hatte halt so füße
immer richtig kreativ ich feiere ich nur
bestätigen kämen alter wie wie vor er
musste sich ja irgendwie so von spiegel
stellen wirklich sehr kreativ aber ob
ich jetzt so mich vor den spiegel
stellen wird und so ein foto machen
würde würde ich bezweifeln
der typ mann vom rollstuhl wenn jemand
dies wirklich dies wirklich richtig geil
oder dies gilt ich finde die folge
januar in eine kirche ja das foto habe
ich auf google gefunden aber du jetzt
also der empfänger hatten in zukunft
wahrscheinlich das video dann wenn du
siehst wie so behältst du dass ich für
dich bist du bescheuert guckt ihr die
mal an du kannst es ja ach du scheiße
[ __ ] junge junge
ich mache auch manchmal so was ich mache
dann irgendwas was passt aber auch sony
die tief in die jetzt auf mich gekommen
vor allem was hat der mann daran ist
dass überhaupt man das sind auf diese
rote großen belt mainz dort fliesst in
batmans dogma der kann doch gar nicht
mehr der weit auch schon du kannst du
nicht einfach weitermachen batman
schwächer bei echten batman es gibt
wirklich so viele verrückte steps
deswegen wenn ihr wollt nächste folge
daumen nach oben einfach können auch
gern kommentar schreiben sonst würd ich
sagen das war es jetzt schon gefallen ja
dann erzeugt gefallen hat dann hat
ich halte gefallen wer ansonsten geht es
hier oben links weiter selbst der server
ist eigentlich linkshänderin meinem
letzten teil von so beeindruckt meinem
jeden jung oder so merkst du merkst du
dass er auf die steht für das projekt
das auf jeden fall mal würde mich freuen
und wir sehen uns am nächsten donnerstag
schon wieder also übermorgen und hat 31